hi in this video we're going to talk
about descriptive statistics and I'm
going to explain the four key components
in a simple way let's say a company
wants to know how its employees travel
to work and so the company creates a
survey to answer this question once
enough data is collected this data can
be analyzed using descriptive statistics
so what is descriptive statistics
descrip statistics aims to describe and
summarize your data in a meaningful way
it provides a simple overview of the
main characteristics of your data but it
is important to note that descriptive
statistics only describe the collected
data without drawing conclusions about
the population to put it simple just
because we know how the employees of one
company get to work we can't say
anything about how all employees of a
whole country get to work making a
statement about the whole population so
for example of all working people in a
country is the task of inferential
statistics to describe data
descriptively we now look at the four
key components measure of central
tendency measure of dispersion frequency
tables and charts let's start with the
first one measures of central attendance
are for example mean median and mode the
arithmetic mean is the sum of all
observations divided by the number of
observations let's look at an example
imagine we have the test scores of five
students 85 90 78 92 and 88 to find a
mean score we add up all the scores and
divide by the number of scores so the
mean test score four of these five
students is
86.6 what about the median when the
values in a data set are arranged in
ascending order the median is the middle
value if there is an odd number of data
points the median is simply the middle
value if there is an even number of data
points the median is the average of the
two middle values it is important to
know that the median is resistant to
extreme values or outliers let's look at
this example no matter how tall the last
person is the person in the middle
Remains the person in the middle so the
median does not change but if we look at
the mean it does have an effect on how
tall the last person is let's continue
with the mode the mode refers to the
value or the values that appear most
frequently
in a data set a few points to note about
the mode if a data set has one value
that appears more frequently than any
other it has one mode and is called uni
modal for example in the data set 2 3 4
4 5 6 7 the mode is four if a data set
has two values that appear most
frequently it has two modes and is
called B mod for instance in this data
set the modes are four and five of
course a data set can also have more
than two modes if it has multiple values
that appear most frequently it is termed
multimodal and some data sets might not
have any repeating values or the
repeating values all have the same
frequency in such cases the data set has
no mode great let's continue continue
with the measures of dispersion measures
of dispersion describe how spread out
the values in a data set are measures of
dispersion are for example variance
standard deviation range and Inter
quartile range let's start with the
standard deviation the standard
deviation indicates the average distance
between each data point and the mean but
slowly each person has some deviation
from the mean now we want to know how
much the persons deviate from the mean
value on average to calculate the
standard deviation we can use this
equation Sigma is the standard deviation
n is the number of persons x e is the
size of each person and x dash is the
mean value of all persons but attention
there are two slightly different
equations for the standard deviation to
keep it simple if our survey doesn't
cover the whole population we always use
this equation likewise if we have
conducted a clinical study then we also
use this equation to infer the
population but what is the difference
between the standard deviation and the
variance as we now know the standard
deviation is the quadratic mean of the
distance from the mean the variance now
is the squar standard deviation if you
want to know more about the standard
deviation and the variance please watch
our video let's go to the range and the
interquartile range it is easy to
understand the range is simply the
difference between the minimum and the
maximum value the inter quartile range
represents the middle 50% of the data it
is the difference between the third
quartile Q3 and the first quartile q1
therefore 25% of the values are smaller
than the inter quartile range and 25% of
the values are larger the interquartile
range contains exactly the middle 50% of
all values before we get to the last
Point Let's briefly compare measures of
central tendency and measures of
dispersion let's say we measured the
blood pressure of patients measures of
central tendency provide a single value
that represents the entire data set
helping to identify a central value
around which data points tend to Cluster
measures of dispersion like the standard
deviation the range and the inter
quartal range indicate how spread out
the data points are whether they are
closely packed around the center or
spread far from it in summary while
measures of central tendency provide a
central point of the data set measures
of dispersion describe how the data set
is spread around that Center let's move
on to tables here we will have a look at
the most important ones contingency
tables also called cross tabs and
frequency tables a frequency table
displays how often each distinct value
appears in a data set let's have a
closer look at this example suppose a
company serveed its employees to find
out how they travel to work the options
given were car bicycle walk and public
transport here are the results from 30
employees we can create a frequency
table to summarize this data to do this
we simply answer the four possible
answer options in the First Column and
then count how often car bicycle walk
and public transport occurred from the
table it's evident that the most common
mode of Transport among the employees is
by car with 11 employees preferring it
the least common is bicycle with five
employees using it this frequency table
provides a clear and concise summary of
the data making it easier to understand
the transportation preferences of the
company's employees but what if we have
a second categorical variable this is
when the contingency table comes in
Imagine the company doesn't have one
Factory but two one in Detroit and one
in Cleveland to be honest I'm not sure
how many people in Detroit and Cleveland
Cycle a walk but it's just an example if
we want to display both values clearly
we can use a contingency table also
called cross tab the RO rows of a
contingency table represent the
categories of one variable while the
columns represent the categories of
another variable each cell in the table
shows the number of observations that
fall into the corresponding category
combination for example the first cell
shows that Carr and Detroit were
answered six times and what about the
charts let's take a look at the most
important ones to do this let's simply
use data TP if you like you can load
this sample data set with the link in
the video description or you just copy
your own data into this table here below
you can see the variables distance to
work mode of transport and site data da
gives you a hint about the level of
measurement but you can also change it
here now if we only click on mode of
Transport we get a frequency table and
we can also display the percentage
values if we scroll down we get a bar
chart and a pie chart here on the left
we can adjust further settings for
example we can specify whether we want
to display the frequencies or the
percentage values or whether the bars
should be vertical or
horizontal if we also select site we get
a cross table here and a grouped bar
chart for the diagrams here we can
specify whether we want the chart to be
grouped or stacked if we click on
distance to work and mode of Transport
we get a bar chart where the height of
the bars shows the mean values of the
individual groups here we can also
display their dispersion we also get a
histogram a box plot a violin plot and a
rainbow plot if you would like to know
more about what a box plot a violin plot
and a rainbow plot are take a look at my
videos I hope you enjoyed the
video